[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, early morning, Semtha, Wealsun.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tyrus and Folsom are sitting there looking up at the stars.
[SPEAKER_00]: There is no fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to give you guys the opportunity to ask me questions about the situation, or if you have any clarifications that you want, I would like to give those to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Question about Redshore, Monmurg, your interactions with...
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen Black, your interactions with the guys in the chart room, any of that.
[SPEAKER_01]: My whole point is to get supplies back to the people of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's all I care about, is relieving that pressure.
[SPEAKER_01]: And unfortunately that is now out the window.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now,
[SPEAKER_01]: If opening up the blockade, if we could somehow clear Man of Wars and these ships could get out of here, those ships could get to Monmurg, that would clear out a... Well, there's no way, because the Turtle Dragons are just blocking that, and the Turtle Dragons are literally in between where that's what's blocking Monmurg from getting all these resources.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, but if we had a way to open up the Turtle Dragons, the maneuver of the Turtle Dragons, we could relieve the people of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what we're going for.
[SPEAKER_01]: This magical flute thing you've got going on?
[SPEAKER_02]: This amulet that was given to...
[SPEAKER_02]: It was Caintoli, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Caintoli has it, which was given to him by a lich named...
[SPEAKER_02]: It starts with an A.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was made by a lich called Aserach.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was not given to him by a necromancer called Ixid, but Ixid told him where it was.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the only thing we can do in order to... You're telling me the only thing to get...
[SPEAKER_01]: Supplies the people of Monmurg is to get this amulet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because otherwise you're going to be taking the little sloops that Owen gave us and be doing that whole four day, three, four day adventure again for the little supplies.
[SPEAKER_02]: When, if we can clear out those turtle dragons, the port will have plenty of more access.
[SPEAKER_02]: The turtle dragons won't be fucking up all that.
[SPEAKER_02]: There won't be any, like, blockades or anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, just so you know, I'm never gonna let you go on your own.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wherever you go, I'm your big
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'll play along and we'll joke and laugh and do whatever we got to do to get through.
[SPEAKER_01]: But just so you know, I'm not going anywhere.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're not going anywhere without me again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Period.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you're not going anywhere without me?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that's good.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not going to leave you to get stuck on some ship all by himself, that's for sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it's because Owen was saying that the ship was for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: And for me, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: He was like, yeah, it's a ship for Tyrus because we were employed by him and now under his thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he was like, this is Tyrus' ship, and then I get on there, and it was all just, he doesn't care about me or anybody else.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, and then there was a... A Toli?
[SPEAKER_02]: A Toli, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: A buddy of his, called Taurus.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so, he's a Toli buddy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Kane Toli.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is his name just Kane?
[SPEAKER_00]: And his last name's Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so the race of people...
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so there's an ancient soul house called the Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: And there is a city called Port Toli, which is in the sea principalities, which is the center of their house.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, if you're a Toli rat, you're from the city.
[SPEAKER_00]: King Toli is one of the noble family.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's why his last name is Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, when I say Owen had a Toli rat on his boat that was porous...
[SPEAKER_00]: It was just his race of the city rats.
[SPEAKER_00]: He could have been half a Radian, half Sewell, who knows, but he was from Port Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he was obviously Sewell.
[SPEAKER_00]: They have a look.
[SPEAKER_00]: As do the people of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, but I'm not gonna let you go on your own anymore.
[SPEAKER_01]: I appreciate that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, we're hooked to the hip.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll let the two sneaky bastards sneak up and do whatever the fuck they gotta do to save our asses.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was gonna say, I mean, back in our Navy days.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right, right.
[SPEAKER_02]: You and I.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not the hip.
[SPEAKER_02]: You and I, brother.
[SPEAKER_02]: But we should listen to Merrick and see his
[SPEAKER_02]: Gouge is aligned with...
[SPEAKER_02]: Prince Jeon.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's aligned with Prince Jeon, and this is his mission.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, but Gouge is aligned with his pocketbook and rum.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's where he's aligned.
[SPEAKER_00]: He actually likes whiskey.
[SPEAKER_00]: The black rum was not something he was into.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, the whiskey.
[SPEAKER_00]: There you go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Too sugary.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's where Gouge is aligned.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gets him too fast.
[SPEAKER_01]: Whiskies, red eye.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, and his frickin' pocketbook.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think after this mission, we should gift Gouge a bottle of red eye.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or kick him in the nuts.
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice bottle of blood.
[SPEAKER_02]: You like him too much.
[SPEAKER_02]: I owe him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, he owes us too.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then I pull out my pocket and show Tyrus the stone.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's this large green gem that you've never seen before.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not a diamond cut, it's a flat cut.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it's probably the most precious.
[SPEAKER_00]: This thing is probably worth 2,000 gold coins.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gouge gave me this for the fact that he just felt I would use it better than he ever could.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're kind of weird about this.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that there's probably a string at the end of that.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's probably something attached to the end of it, knowing that Gouge motherfucker.
[SPEAKER_01]: The only thing Gouge told me
[SPEAKER_02]: When I have the stone, he was like, this is yours, just make sure you have my back.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I cannot go back on someone who I feel more empowered holding this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, well, there's probably another reason why.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the only reason why is so he can watch his back, that's for damn sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: But, where we are, they're not, again, just to clarify, not the best.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not the best with Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who?
[SPEAKER_00]: The Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, Red Shore is from the country of Keoland.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're part of Keoland.
[SPEAKER_00]: Red Shore and Monmurg are not on bad terms because there's trade that goes through there.
[SPEAKER_00]: But the Duke of Gratzel does not like the fact that Monmurg is so rich.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he's the one blockading.
[SPEAKER_00]: So the Earl of Red Shore
[SPEAKER_00]: His authority is basically based on Grazzle.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's probably stuck in between all of this.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's probably what the deal is.
[SPEAKER_01]: He probably had a much happier life when all of this shit wasn't happening.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was gonna say, we should... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's very possible.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, he probably...
[SPEAKER_00]: He doesn't want this crap.
[SPEAKER_00]: He doesn't want people being killed in the street or the chart room or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's the biggest dick in the smallest pond right now at this place here, because this ain't a no place, and now he's getting fucked on all sides.
[SPEAKER_02]: He has Redshore going under because of the blockage as well with Turtle Dragons.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, Red Shore has... First off, Red Shore does really good business whaling.
[SPEAKER_00]: They make whaling.
[SPEAKER_00]: They make oil.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nothing can go nowhere right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: But their ports are blocked by these.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm sure that the Earl of Red Shore has already bought all the shit he wants from these guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: Spice, whatever.
[SPEAKER_00]: But at some point, you can only drink so much great wine before you die.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he's probably like...
[SPEAKER_00]: This is fucking my shit up.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a war right on my face.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he probably would rather have this fought anywhere else but on his shore right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I think.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if we can sneakily happily get into there, make a deal with him, I'm willing to bet there's a deal to be made.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think not even making a deal, I think we should just tell him that we should first see if he's aligned with Cain Toi at all.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because he's aligned with the Duke of Gratzel, correct?
[SPEAKER_00]: So he is a subject of the Duke of Gratzel.
[SPEAKER_00]: So if you go in there, you'd be probing him to get information about what's going on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll see which one at the time befriends his beauty the most, and see which one of us beautiful people befriends him the best at the time.
[SPEAKER_02]: We also serve King Jameis as well under his fleet, correct?
[SPEAKER_00]: Prince Gian is your lord because you are from Monmurg and you're loyal to the city.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am loyal to the people.
[SPEAKER_01]: We should bring that up.
[SPEAKER_01]: We don't even worry about that.
[SPEAKER_01]: We just need to get him on board with what?
[SPEAKER_01]: Break the blockade and see whatever we need to do and we'll find out who has the sweeter face to make that happen.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's no way we can break the blockade because if we start to go down, the turtle dragons are right there and we're dead.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can't.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're not.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because we got this magic amulet crystal farting thing that you got.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ain't that big green lock you got in your pocket?
[SPEAKER_01]: I hate to tell you that, I can't control the turtle dragons.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe I can.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, this is not the Turtle Dragon amulet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, we gotta get the Turtle Dragon amulet.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, we'll find out which one can do it at the time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.